my TikToks have clearly found the wrong side recently
but I just wanna say something
these type of comments will never ever
ever affect me
because I have always had a very strong and high level of self esteem
and I have also always had a really strong moral compass
I remember when I was
I think 16
and I went to a music festival
and there were guys with placards who were rating out of 10
all the girls that walked past
and I knew at the time that that was wrong and that was like over 10 years ago
I recognise at a really early age that men are always gonna do this
and that I needed to create safeguards inside myself
that would not to do with my physical appearance
I recognise that I was gonna age
and I knew that if I put all of my confidence and self esteem on how I looked
that I would at some stage become very unhappy with myself
I recognised that society was asking me to do that
to put all of my energy and money into how I looks
and that I would be rewarded as a woman for doing that
and that that is a trap and I thought about that a lot when I was young
like my late teens my early 20s
I thought about that a lot and how to overcome that
I decided to put a lot of therapy and energy into not
becoming a woman who was completely attached to the way I look
and needing that type of external validation
especially from men in order to feel good about myself
so I have been training for this for a long time
and I luckily have a very strong sense of self worth
and I also know that I'm hot
like it's not a question it's not something that I'm gonna ever ask myself
I know
like I just know on a deep level and it's nothing you say is gonna change that
it doesn't matter how outspoken I am and how much I annoy you
and how much I say things that are gonna annoy you
there's nothing that you can say to change my mind or these issues
or to make me feel bad about myself
fortunately
I love myself and I have a wonderful partner and he absolutely adores me
I have incredible friends who absolutely adore me
I have amazing family who absolutely adore me
there is nothing that you can say that's gonna be the mic drop moment
you think it is
and I know this won't stop trolls cause that's not how trolls work
but I just want to put that out there
it is not doing what you think it's doing